2012 while you were probably watching
the Olympics and celebrating the Queen's
Jubilee this lot were hatching a plan in
a pub near Kings Cross the ringleader
was 76 year old Brian reader known as
the master or governor he played a part
in the Brinks MACT robbery in 1983 as
well after three years of planning the
date was set the master even used a
senior citizen travel pass to get to
Hatton Garden the gang went in with a
10-ton hydraulic ram but it didn't work
properly the alarm went off and alerted
the Met Police but they didn't respond
the gang came back two nights later over
the Easter weekend
they used a diamond-tipped drill to get
into the vault and made off with
fourteen million pounds worth of jewels
gold and cash from 73 safe deposit boxes
they would have got away with it but
CCTV caught them out
looks like the forensics for dummies
manual they used didn't quite cut it one
of the men Danny Jones wrote to Sky News
saying he would reveal where some of the
stash was hidden turns out it was in
Edmonton Cemetery two whole dolls packed
with jewelry and precious stones were
found under a bank of plaques marking
buried ashes a third of the loot now
been found around London including
banknotes stuffed under a microwave
these men threatened the livelihoods of
40 people including jewellers and other
shop owners and ten million pounds worth
of stolen goods are still missing so too
is one of the Raiders